thank you
[Music]
so I think this room is full of tough
guts I would say it's got a lot of tough
guys in it and I would say that we know
about weapons we know about self-defense
yeah we know how to protect our home yep
you know I do with my hot Cheeto fingers
I [__] poke it in their eyes that's
poison oh that's burning that's better
than like mace I think that's right if
we had the Navy SEAL guys here again the
special ops they would have been like oh
Joe dangerous it's always got the Right
Moves that's what you do you need to
back away right away repeat the weapon
so I'm gonna show you guys a clip and
you guys we're all gonna weigh in the
answer is yes but it is avoiding a gun
the easiest [__] thing of all time
yeah dude check it out or or no in space
of all time in space what do you mean
avoiding like someone's shooting at you
somebody pulls a gun on you is that
maybe the probably the [__] easiest
thing you could ever avoid ever probably
we're gonna decide we're gonna let this
you know they're only gonna they're
gonna be interesting it depends on how
far they are
you gave him everything he's still got
that gun pointed at you your goal is to
get as close to the weapon as possible
ideally he's even pointing at your head
trying to scare you away this is a
benefit so that you can actually get off
the line as quick as you can because I'm
gonna be turned out of the way I [__]
hate these disarming videos dude hold it
into your chest rip it off smash smash
tap rack and go with me one of his
record so is he a student of that
Detroit urban survival guy or what
don't know that he is
he is but this guy knows how to get it
done can I say something I have a I have
actually an honest like um
feeling about these videos yeah please
um part of me goes
I [__] wish that'll work though part
of me is like yeah I think I could pull
it off yeah
but then as soon as somebody puts a gun
in my face and it's a fake gun I freeze
I freeze the [__] up dude dude I get
scared if you're out in a parking lot
right there and as soon as someone goes
like this even if you just [__]
Sprint as fast as you can away what are
they gonna do zigzag yeah zigzag too and
then they're not gonna start shooting
you because they want your money unless
they're a school shooter or someone
that's just crazy they could just be
impulsively stupid that's true too if
you take one Jiu Jitsu class
in the Jiu Jitsu class there's always a
move of the day and you practice it for
like 20 minutes straight yeah the minute
you do a live roll everything that can
go wrong goes wrong it doesn't even work
yeah that thing someone teaching you
from a video will not work at all
because literally in Jiu Jitsu like I'm
drilling he's really I'm drilling we're
doing that move 20 minutes right and
then live roll happens and it doesn't
even go to plan yeah that's true exactly
that's true more I just want to give you
guys a little bit more expert footage
just safety tip at home this is what you
need to do in these situations well he's
the master and he's the biggest man of
all time
[Music]
Aikido world champion oh oh [__] he put
his finger in the trigger though yeah so
whoa that's a slow motion by the way
that was fast and that is slow motion
right there and also he's probably the
only guy that can pull off a do-rag like
that I mean he's never been shot he can
also eat a Hostess apple pie while he's
doing it
you know what which which channel I kind
of like
um is active self-protection because
this guy will do teachings but he'll
show real footage of actual robberies
where a guy did the thing he's talking
about oh that's time is that the fat
white guy you've seen him yeah yeah
because at least he's not saying hey do
what I'm doing he's like okay here we
have a guy who's over here he gets
robbed he does his thing and this is how
it turned out and it's not always good
it's not always ideal sometimes the guys
still get shot but he lived but like
shit's like it's always like those
things are like it's always ugly you
know I mean like like a real fight is
never what it seems like there's no two
situations that were like chaos dude and
you're always unsettled it doesn't feel
there's even videos that he pulls out
about like where the the the victim is
armed but they pull it too late or
whatever and then it's just right
[__] or they're too nervous to like
this is John Korea
well it's real life scenarios really
well lit yeah
it's almost like they have multiple
cameras on here whoa
as a guy who has a gun you definitely
want to go right up to the guy oh my God
it's pretty amazing that that like
feels like this whoa no but you know
what he did first the key is that before
you swing your arm you have to go
because you have to Telegraph it a
little bit get the motion and the JK
crew safely say that if you actually if
you're able to get shot you're just a
[__] dumb you're dumb idiot you're
stupid it's like you don't know how to
move your shoulders yeah and who walks
toward a gun yeah only gangsters that
are not afraid of death children who
don't know or if somebody has a gun you
got to do this move this is a trump card
you go [__] pull it [__] do it
you know what I mean if you're too
aggressive dude do you have a real
honest reflex in your body of what to do
if someone were to pull a gun on you
personally cry sit to my butt go ahead
do it do it Bart so you pull a gun you
go all right then
[Laughter]
if someone pulls out a gun on a boxer
he's like fight like a man right if it's
a Jujitsu dude he's like he's fighting
like a man yeah it sits on the ground
enter your doom idiot yeah this is kind
of what I do this bro this self-defense
mechanism is kind of what Nick was was
uh intimating
yeah
oh what do you want to hear man do you
want to hear that sometimes I think
about eating a bullet
I do I even got a special one for the
occasion with a hollow point look make
sure it blows the back of my goddamn
head out do the job right
every single day I wake up and I think
of a reason not to do it every single
dude men are so [__] good at arguing
he took a oath dude hate to be in afraid
let's take my gun don't nibble on the
barrel pull a trigger go ahead pal yeah
he might just go ahead
good morning
[Laughter]
[Music]
you really are [__] crazy oh my God
legendary incredible dude and the worst
thing is this it's Danny uh Glover's
birthday
and he's like I got partnered with a
[__] loaded weapon maybe some maybe
even a vehicle crazy
that is a self-defense attack no for
sure like put the gun in your mouth and
you go [__] do it
because then already it's like I'm crazy
I'm willing to lose everything yeah if
you're a security guard and they're
robbing the bank you should do this yeah
and then they'll be like the [__] I'm
gonna put the money down and I'll
[__] pull it hey man drop the gun
dude I'll kill myself hey dude you got a
family I'm sure you're like I don't want
this on my conscience man
your [__] making a cool chick on on an
app right
you have so much going for you and he's
like oh don't remind me the app that's
why I'm doing this remember this is sure
as soon as he hears the app your side
house is going to pick up I probably get
in any matches man I'm not getting any
[__] matches dude
they dried up they [__] dried up
postco but I swear to God every [__]
was talking to people
I just can't sign up for premium man no
one's giving me any [__] super likes
hmm
Joseph how would you avoid a gun
I think um
it's all about the element of surprise
so I would immediately start taking off
my clothes that's that's honestly a good
enough strategy that sounds like
misdirection
call it okay and then you take off your
pants and what if he's like yeah
I want something else no
not money
and then I'm like you want money come
and get it
honey it's really good yeah it's good
advice I think that'll save a lot of
lives
hopefully hopefully people learned a lot
from this I feel like you could just
[__] hug somebody
you just grab them because you're such a
big large man I like what Joe's saying
though I think I would probably just
start jerking off or something crazy oh
yeah oh that's a good one yeah it's like
it just be a sex offender
you go to jail you're trying to commit
to it you can't get hard
he's like oh what happened big man what
happened
or die what's up you don't like me yeah
you think I'm cute
that is true though you can't backfire
yeah
some people get horny during stresses so
people like that yeah do you feel like
you like that if it's too hot if it's
too hard I can't get hurt really too hot
it's too hot I thought you said if it's
too hard
oh that's too hard so it gets really
hard and it goes right back down yeah
if it's too hot I think he only got one
second for this
hurry up it's too hard
if it's too cold
forget about it yeah too cold though
really gonna be just right exactly how
about if you're listening to Pandora and
the ad comes on like ah [__] and it
ruins it what if your phone rings I
can't get hurt
I can't get hard at all
oh yeah that's a good one who's at ten
dollars dude oh
can't get hard till 20 baby
let's ride
what if Wu's going like this but then
right when you're about to come cardano
goes like this